April I want to drive around the BMW and
shoot people would sniper bro our minion
sniper American sniper this film I think
is a very important piece of war drama
it's dark it's incredibly haunting but
very emotionally captivating like if you
don't feel your emotions while watching
this movie you are dead on the inside so
[ __ ] you 75 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
is pretty good but I'm honestly
surprised this film didn't get a higher
rating so [ __ ] you rotten tomatoes what
you really got to know is this film
stands alone on Bradley Cooper's
performances Chris Kyle those of you who
don't know who Chris Kyle is he's
considered the most deadly sniper of all
time with over a hundred and sixty kills
that's about as many woman as I had
never been with say myself baby I
thought this was going to be like a
typical war drama where it's like a nice
American Joe and then he goes to war and
then he just takes out all his trauma on
everyone around him which can be
effective but I think we've kind of
become immune to that structure while
this movie does have some of those
elements it doesn't feel like super
familiar it still feels fresh it's
different it's essentially telling two
stories one is about a husband who's
married to this was really a hot woman
who's kind of a [ __ ] at first but she's
pretty hot and he's a soon-to-be father
you know you got a plant one in before
you go off to war but he's like
emotionally retreating from them due to
the war and then there's actually this
other story that I'm surprised a lot of
people haven't been commenting on which
is about Chris Kyle on the SEAL team and
he has a very specific man hunt mission
the film goes back and forth to him
going on tour not concert tour what war
tour then coming back home the story of
a family man whose personal life is
deteriorating because of the war trauma
it's subtly told and it's very powerful
like few movies like this actually
really get me and this one got me then
the story of the manhunt is like
gripping and it's intense and the well
by Clint Eastwood's direction but like I
said this film truly
to Bradley Cooper everything about this
film is good but it all centers around
making Bradley Cooper that much better
he does more than carry this film he is
the film there wasn't a single flaw in
this guy's portrayal right down to the
physicality every emotional note was
just perfect he clearly went to the same
commercial acting classes I went to when
I was 14 there's so much you can analyze
sis from this one performance he's
clearly going to go on an emotional
character journey throughout this film
but not one moment was black-and-white
there was always a full life in every
single moment prior to him going to war
he's 100% believable you love the guy
he's really nice and then when he's
enlisting and he's in the training
sequences which just [ __ ] look brutal
like we don't need to work out that much
do we then when he is in the war without
one scene that they show in the trailer
where he has to like sniper the the
little boy and he doesn't know what to
do that's a very powerful moment and it
really defines a lot of the character
for like a lot of the film just so you
know I would've shop a little kid
no questions asked it's an interesting
film because like there's war action in
this film but it's definitely not
glorified it really feels like you're in
the war everyone's personalities are
very real amongst the troops yet as you
watch Chris Kyle grow into this
legendary sniper you can't help but
think kind of badass that's kind of
badass this performance was more about
building a ton of emotion but then
containing it not exposing or remoting
all of it to try to get an Oscar
nomination it's a very subtle
performance but damn it's so powerful
like there's this scene where he's
crying at a bar that one moment alone is
not powerful because he's like a weeping
willow yeah one moment alone is powerful
because he's clearly trying not to cry
and that's more realistic you know a lot
of actors will just bawl in real life we
tried not to cry when he's at home he
feels like he's not himself he feels
like he should be back in the war he's
really just disconnected from humanity
his family and then when he's in the war
suddenly his personality like returns
it's heartbreaking to watch because the
war zone is becoming his home and all
you want is for this guy to return back
to his actual home and his wife and kids
they could plan another one in the oven
every
these centers around Bradley Cooper's
performance so whatever flaws you may
find with this film none of it matters
what really matters is the portrayal of
Chris Kyle and his performance keep
saying it absolutely perfect and I hope
to god he wins the Academy Award do you
hear that god you hear that when we get
straight to the point here all in all I
gotta say American sniper got it
[ __ ] right all right guys
thanks for checking to my review for
American sniper why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me who you sniper and last mile at least
if you want to get updated every tonne
of my reviews or videos this out go
ahead and click on this button by my
dick to subscribe that's right dick let
me tell you something about this little
American every time he takes aim at a
lady he never takes the shot because
he's in love he's in love that's right
[ __ ] you [ __ ]